numa último vídeo eu pedi para vocês
comentarem arroz e se nós chegássemos
aos 100 comentários eu tinha de colocar
um vídeo por dia este mês e bom
conseguimos né Sem comentários a dizer
arroz Eu Admito que vai ser um pouco
difícil de voltar aqui ao ritmo Ok de
colocar um vídeo por dia ter ideias
desenvolver tudo eu aproveitei já com o
meu estúdio não estava optimizado para
postar um vídeo por dia né porque eu
tenho que ter as coisas Preparadas estão
ali ah tive aqui a organizar o estúdio
mais uma vez e eu descobri que comecei a
colecionar Fundos e como é que eu
descobri isto porque eu eu de repente já
estou aguardar as caixas sabem estes
aqui são os meus próprios antigos os que
eu já tenho há muito tempo e do nada
comecei a comprar Pops que estão ali em
cima se tu compras um copo tu tiras o
pop da caixa porque ele tem de estar
disposto sabe e eu agora comecei a
guardar a caixa comecei a a comprar
apenas os Pops que tem a curva da Caixa
completamente 100% sabe então ya eu acho
que estou a começar com o Pops e vou
aproveitar já que estou aqui a organizar
o estudo Eu quero vos mostrar quais é
que eu já tenho as cagadas que eu fiz
antes de começar a selecionar tipo eu
tenho aqui hipóteses muito caro mas como
estão sem caixa já desvalorizaram tudo e
se ele tivesse guardado a caixa Man eu
já tenho uma coleção aqui bem razoável
antes de começarmos a ver aqui os Pops
Muito obrigado a Biônico ponto PT é uma
loja aqui em Portugal super confiável
onde vocês podem comprar smartphones
câmeras de segurança aspiradores tudo
para vossa casa tem pobres também
inclusive eles mandaram-me imensos Pops
então vou deixar o link aqui embaixo na
descrição pessoal podem passar lá em
breve vamos ter um código promocional de
10% de desconto portanto se pamem aí
bien o nick eu vou-vos passar esse
código inclusive eles também me enviaram
um inspirador depois eu vou-vos mostrar
aqui em vídeo é muito muito sugador é um
inspirador que sugar as vossas amigas
sabem boas foram super impecáveis comigo
e enviar-me aqui alguns Pops e meu e o
que eu adorei a embalagem veio perfeita
este vecna tá em perfeito estado eu vou
admitir eu comecei esta coleção também
na questão de valorização okay eu anda à
procura dos Pops que eu gosto mas os que
eu sei que também poderão ter algum
valor no futuro okay e convém que a
embalagens esteja completamente a 100%,
né Eu já cometi o erro de encomenda
online de lojas duvidosas em que a caixa
vem toda arrebentada o plástico vem todo
desfeito Man na biúnico vem tudo
perfeito tenho meu eles enviaram o quê
cerca de 15 Pops 12 Pops vem todos em
condição excelente assim ó com os cantos
todos perfeitos tudo impecávelmente
adorei tá aí o link embaixo pessoal
passem lá vamos começar aqui pelo vecner
o nosso amigo invek na Vila stranger
things tá incrível ele tem tipo assim a
mãozinha para a frente okay eu não sei
se conseguem ver o vecchnel mais ao pé
esquerdo tá muito lindo eu vou já deixar
aqui o nosso amigo Lucas Okay Como podem
ver Caixa em estado Impecável nosso
amigo Lucas stranger things temos aqui
uma Eleven que eu acho que não é deste
pack eu acho que não é desta coleção e
há esta outra coleção aparentemente
estrangeiro tem que ter mais coleções
que eu não sabia okay eu ainda estou
muito Verde aqui neste mundo dos Pops Ok
ainda não percebo assim tanto mas acho
que eu vou encontrando que eu gosto eu
vou comprando e assim vamos começando a
coleção a bom ritmo devagarinho uma
pessoa que
temos aqui o nosso amigo Mike tem ali os
óculoszinhos dele temos aqui o nosso
amigo dusting ele vem com um rádio ele
tem um rádio ali na mão e tem também a
t-shirt do El Fire Club Olha aí este
assim eu gosto porque tem muitos
pormenores tipo tem aqui certo tem o
rádio tem os óculos tem o boné louco
louco o próximo é louco temos aqui o
nosso amigo é e esta é uma edição
especial porque só conseguem encontrar
aqui nesta loja têm aqui o Sticker é um
exclusivo Ah ele vem com uma guitarra é
uma edição especial okay eu já tentei
filtrar pelo preço dele e não consegui
encontrar porque ele é muito recente
ainda mas eu acredito que em nível de
valorização este Vai ter muito valor
porque é uma edição especial Okay
próximo Claro temos aqui o nosso valor
Freire esta aqui saiu bem pouco tempo é
bastante recente tem também o barulho de
foxy eu não comprei ainda porque eu não
consegui encontrar em bom estado mas eu
consegui encontrar aqui este Fred é em
bom estado e eu sou louco por fregues
Então temos aqui o balão de Fred e temos
aqui outro stranger things
eu não sei se conseguem ver aí mas está
muito louco mais um popzinho Donald's eu
vou admitir que só comprar esta figura
porque ele está numa posição assim meio
estranha tipo com ar zangado né tá bem
louco então só comprei mesmo pela
posição temos aqui um também que eu
adorei
Pinóquio tá aqui o nosso amigo Pinóquio
com o grilo Ah isso aqui é o Pinóquio de
madeira mesmo e tem aqui o grilo dentro
Eu achei esta uma versão muito louca
porque Tecnicamente Vem quando dois Pops
aqui dentro então é acabei por comprar
muito louco e este é o maior pobre que
eu tenho aqui pessoal
Ai meu Deus não posso estragar a caixa
assim esta aqui também foi enviado pela
bionick.pt Ok em condição excelente
reparem nos cantos da Caixa está tudo
Impecável perfeito temos aqui o nosso
Milton Olha aí isso incrível pessoal eu
tenho ali um Charizard que não é um Pop
Ok mas eu quero abrir o YouTube e
deixá-lo ali ao lado dele comentem aí o
que é que vocês acham pessoal abram este
Pop ou não abram este pop aqui ou não
comentem aí um que eu gostei muito
também e este praticamente saiu um de
borla temos aqui o wellingte mais o ET
aqui a andar de bicicleta tá muito lindo
este aqui é um bordo porque eu estava a
passear numa loja onde eles estavam a
fazer uma promoção de Pops onde era Pago
dois Live três então Este foi o terceiro
que eu levei saiu de bordo e os outros
ainda me saíram em promoção ou seja os
dois que eu levei estavam em promoção e
o terceiro ainda não saiu de bordo
próximo temos aqui mais um de Pokémon
Olha aí o nosso amigo pichu em versão
flacker a versão foca é quando o pop Tem
sim aquela textura tipo um tecido sabe
tipo um veludo então Ya tá aqui o nosso
picho muito lindo eu vou começar uma
coisa eu não muito fácil de Pokémon mas
há Pokémon que me chamam bastante
atenção o meu tour é um deles o charizar
é um deles também o pichu eu não acho
assim grande coisa mas como está em
versão flauta e tem este selo aqui pá
acaba por ter assim mais algum algum
valor e tudo mais então eu acabei por
comprar o só porque sim só para ver o
que é que dava agora dentro da caixa tem
aqui os meus três favoritos os que eu
tenho até agora vamos começar por esta
edição especial que é do Jack sequela
então ele brilha no escuro eu tenho aqui
dois selos tem aqui se fecham ainda Dark
OK agora estes dois aqui são incríveis
Malta Jacks que ela entende e esta é uma
edição que é nightwis OK tem assim as
cores bem trocadas tá muito louco ele é
assim meio amarelo meio roxo e este aqui
sem dúvida é uma favorita de todos dos
que eu tenho em caixa Olha aí cheque e
versão night vision se fecha ali deixa
Malta este aqui foi difícil encontrar é
um cheque para mim vale eu nunca vi este
pop aqui à venda à toa assim tipo numa
flanaco ou numa loja como mencionar
então ya para mim foi um achado bom
dentro das Caixa s é isto tudo agora
vamos aqui ver os Pops que eu tenho fora
da caixa e que eu não devia ter aberto e
eu aqui foi um bocado de burro porque eu
tenho Pops até valiosas aqui e perderam
o valor tipo este
tipo este Nightmare Freddy
Nightmare Freddy Glow in the Dark fora
da caixa este pop aqui Vale cerca de 70
dólares 80 dólares é por aí eu aqui já
tinha algum lucro mas mesmo assim o pop
é muito lindo Ok outro pobre muito lindo
cupcake das Chica este aqui é incrível
eu adoro este pop muito bom a minha
intenção agora pessoal é vender estes
Pops todos eh e comprar os que eu
realmente gosto dentro de caixa ou seja
vende aqui estes todos e depois compro
este dentro da caixa este dentro da
caixa e mais um ou dois o resto é para
vender eu acho balon boy muito lindo
também adorava ter a caixa dele enfim é
o que é ainda por cima os próprios vêm
com uma base em plástico onde Vocês
conseguem manter o pop de pé ah este não
se aguenta de pé e eu tirei a base fora
com a caixa
todos os dias temos aqui mais um Fred
porque eu adoro freddy's eh eu não sei
que Fred é este mas hã fantime Fried e
talvez comentem aí se eu tiver a dizer
bosta um Iron Man
bubblete este aqui também acho que vale
alguma coisa este aqui acho que tem
algum valor Este foi o primeiro pop da
história que eu tive Frankenstein
aparentemente isto aqui também é errado
porque era uma edição da Universal tem
muitos frankensteins por aí mas com esta
posição não então ya Acho que perdi
algum dinheiro aqui também um Capitão
América não sei como é que eu tenho isto
deve ter sido alguém que me ofereceu
Olha aí a nossa amiga não é belo também
foi um inscrito que me ofereceu okay eu
lembro-me que alguém me oferece estar na
Bela num evento no item temos aqui um
fox lindo lindo este aqui se não me
engano é cheddao Shadow Fox e fent-te-me
foxy a qualquer coisa assim Acho que ele
tenta me foxy comentem e se tiver a
falar bosta Malta o nosso amigo Fred é
Fox e desculpem Olha aí esse aqui acho
que é o Nightmare Fox inclusive fant
foxy funtime foxy ou mangle não é
fantame foxy tá aqui fantame foxy temos
aqui um personagem
Ok mas eu não sei não é o animal lactor
é outro personagem qualquer mas eu não
sei quem é enfim tá aqui ui quem é ele
sai também eu gostava muito ter a caixa
dele agora de yu-gi-oh porque eu adoro
yu-gi-oh temos aqui o nosso amigo caiba
com uma carta na mão muito lindo este
aqui também gostava de ter a caixa
esquece Foi muito burreter a tirar das
Caixas fora enfim Olha aí Andar como é
muito louco estes aqui de yu-gi-o ainda
tem algum valor Ok e temos aqui ui quem
é que temos aqui também esse aqui é o
último Malta Blue white white Dragon
versão super cabeçuda esta gigante
comparem só é um Pop normal olha aí em
comparação ao Saitama é gigante tá aqui
logo mais traga Malta a minha intenção é
vender estes todos agora e comprar pelo
menos quatro com o valor destes todos eu
compro quatro com caixa ok e é isso não
tem como um vídeo por dia pessoal já
sabe
que comem beijão com arroz se querem
mesmo ver um vídeo aqui no canal e é
isso pessoal fica bem e até a próxima